I'm Morgan Freeman narrator of the
upcoming IMAX documentary born to be
wild join me on the journey of a
lifetime to meet orphaned orangutans and
elephants we will follow the paths of
two extraordinary women who have
dedicated their lives to rescuing
raising and ultimately releasing these
animals back to the wild
we're gonna be wild is not a wildlife um
it's it's um that stars wild animals but
it's about two women working to help
these elephants in orangutans orphans
get back to the wild
the elephant story is set in a couple
parts of Kenya in Nairobi National Park
and in Tsavo National Park theme Daphne
Daphne Sheldrick spent 60 years raising
these orphan elephants and giving her
heart to these elephants before Daphne
nobody had ever successfully raised an
infant elephant I think everyone should
be aware of the natural world and do
what they can to protect and preserve it
Daphne's husband David started what
became the biggest National Park at
Kenya that place is the shelter for the
largest wild herds of elephants that are
left in Kenya when David first went
there there wasn't even a road no there
wasn't anything so he built that pup
literally from nothing the orangutans
story is set on the island of Borneo in
Indonesia it's very very remote dr breen
gulf coast is probably the world's
foremost expert on orangutans
I went into the field almost 40 years
ago there was no roads no telephones
there was virtually no electricity you
see what it is that she had to deal with
you know with the swamps the leeches the
insects the heat the humidity I mean
this is one of the most uncompromising
places that I've ever been and she came
here and pioneered this whole process of
how you get these young orangutangs back
into the forest
both orangutans and elephants they're
killed and they leave babies behind both
of these ladies have made it their lives
worth to live for these orphans and they
have incredible organizations that
they've set up to do this
Daphne Sheldrick is the first person to
ever successfully raise in its Intel so
you know they weren't living this
they're happy so we've got to keep them
as happy as possible and that's not
giving them what they want
little des was entertaining them playing
with them for core just like human
children
the orangutan is at the care center
range from probably two weeks old
to seven or eight years old they go
through their infancy of toddler stage
they really go through every stage of
development that we see in human
children caregivers what they do is they
take the around the counts into the
forest every day
and luckily Ronnie tuggs teach each
other after about two years the little
orphan elephants move out to this
facility and Tsavo National Park there
they're surrounded by wild elephants
it's like first day at boarding school
these elephants take over from the
people they take the waterholes they
show them where to eat at the end of the
day the elephants come back because
there's still milk dependent it's a very
gradual process that's just amazing to
be around you know raising the elephants
is a rollercoaster this is a 50-year
learning curve you don't just give up
born to be wild is an ideal story to
tell in IMAX 3d not just see it you know
but really be there in a way that you
can't in another format IMAX 3d you're
right there you're inside the picture
and this is right I think IMAX 3d films
have a better chance of getting the
gentleness and the personality we can
see it better it has to reach an
emotional level not just an intellectual
level logistically this film was
incredibly complicated we had a massive
amount of equipment that we had to move
halfway around the world we've assembled
one of the best crews in the world for
this kind of film because when you see
the equipment we're working with it's
way beyond what's done in any other
documentary for this film we did indeed
build a tower first IMAX for digital 3d
camera we've been able to capture
that we could never get on film there
seems that happened in a fast way you
can't do take two you have to be there
and ready we're making a film about
animals that are on their way back to
the wild the unpredictable happens they
do things you don't expect they don't go
places and think they're gonna go they
don't behave the way you think they're
always gonna behave it's just kind of go
out of control
both really called accosts and Daphne
Sheldrick are huge inspirations in the
truest sense there she rose of the earth
I really love around the towns and I
think we have a responsibility to make
sure they don't go extinct I think
people will see this film and they'll
get it they'll get what's going on and
they'll want to help whatever way they
can every single species contributes
towards the well-being of the planet as
a whole it's the only place we have and
we've got to take care of it if we don't
know about these other creatures of the
struggles they have to make it in this
world we just quietly go along doing
what we're doing it's not just something
to talk about is for real